i want to talk about netflix today
netflix had a massive crash to their
stock price not long ago after it was
announced that for the first time ever
netflix actually lost net subscribers
now any subscriber based business has
some of what we call churn which is
subscribers turn over we also have that
we have a membership program to fund our
program and if in a day you have a
hundred people sign up and 20 cancel
you've got a certain level of churn but
you're still coming out ahead by 80
subscribers and what netflix for the
first time has experienced is a net
decline in subscribers
stock price collapsed
very quickly and many different opinions
about what's going on and i want to give
you my sense of what's taking place with
netflix
first a really quick word from our
sponsor morning brew if you're like me
and i know many of you are in different
ways you probably spend some of your day
kind of mindlessly scrolling through
twitter
or reddit and kind of coming across news
articles but not really taking in
what's going on in the world today
morning brew lets you soak up the entire
day's news
in a focused way that takes about five
minutes a day it's a way better use of
your time morning brews a free daily
newsletter it's seven days a week in
about five minutes morning brew gets me
caught up on politics business finance
tech just what's going on in the world
in a much more focused and efficient way
much better use of my time they take all
the day's news stories and boil them
down into
just the most important points so you'll
be informed about what's taking place
maybe you like watching the david pakman
show because i take stories
hopefully break them down and give you
the important takeaways and something to
think about that's exactly what morning
brew does but morning brew will keep you
in the loop on more than just politics
like i said when you have a few minutes
of downtime on your phone
don't get bogged down in either clicking
around or one long news article you're
never actually going to finish
that's where morning brew is perfect you
get a well-crafted
series of bite-size articles and you get
through them quickly and you're informed
subscribe to morningbrew right now using
the link below
okay so is netflix losing subscribers
because there are too many alternatives
is netflix losing subscribers because
they increase their prices too much too
quickly is netflix losing subscribers
because they've gone woke as some people
have said
um i think that there's a combination of
things that are going on here
one of the advantages to netflix
is the same advantage that tesla has had
for some period of time which is first
mover advantage
tesla was the first to have a long
long-range electric vehicle be widely
available many of the earlier electric
vehicles were either hybrid where they
were electric for a little bit and then
switched to gas or just have a low
electric range
tesla committed to 100 electric vehicles
early whatever your opinion is about
elon musk they did it well enough that
they had this first mover advantage now
as i've said before as a tesla owner
myself
other companies are better at making
cars than tesla
for now because they've been doing it a
lot longer when you look at the audi
e-tron when you look at even electric
vehicles by ford and chevy doesn't have
to be in the luxury space these
companies have been making vehicles for
a really long time and so when they
catch up in terms of range to tesla
tesla will likely suffer unless they can
do something lower the price improve the
cars even more
some kind of marketing campaign that
convinces people get a tesla anyway and
many companies are now getting close to
tesla in terms of range the new audi
e-tron later this year will have uh
basically the range of a tesla the
mercedes eqs etc okay so the first mover
advantage will start to go away
similarly netflix had that first mover
advantage when it came to
sort of like top tier
licensing for movies and shows as well
as high-speed streaming
and they benefited greatly from that
we
saw the wave that netflix road
coincide perfectly with the increased um
availability of high-speed internet
which lets people stream high definition
and 4k content but then over time as it
became less of a novelty
uh you saw other players enter the
market and depending on what you're
interested in
netflix may no longer be the option for
you a lot we have curiosity stream as a
sponsor which specializes in
documentaries
if you really love documentaries you
might not want to pay 14 bucks a month
for netflix when you can pay 15 a year
for curiosity stream if you like a
certain type of film that is on amazon
prime
video rather than netflix you might say
i've already got amazon prime i don't
need netflix i've got plenty of stuff
through amazon prime
hulu roku all these different things
apple tv etc so there's a fragmentation
and there's the loss of netflix
first mover advantage i think all of
these things are absolutely true
in addition to that there's a timing
aspect early in the pandemic with
everybody being stuck at home
subscriptions for everything went crazy
for our show too we saw it as well
and then as slowly people are getting
back to doing the things that they did
before going to sporting events going to
movies travel all these different things
many people are saying i have more
subscriptions than i need and just by
statistics
if netflix is one of five or one of
eight or one of ten subscriptions you
have some people are going to choose to
cancel netflix so i think it's in all of
the above now do i think netflix going
woke is part of what's going on i don't
i have to tell you i don't and if
somebody wants to change my mind on that
by all means feel free but i do not see
that as one of the reasons for netflix
uh burning off subscribers let me know
what you think